roger federer has announced his
retirement from tennis the 20-time grand
slam singles champion says the lava cup
in london later this month is going to
be his final event
federer posted this message on his
twitter this afternoon
i want to thank you all from the bottom
of my heart to everyone around the world
who has helped make the dreams of a
young swiss ball kid come true
finally to the game of tennis
i love you
and will never leave you
well i'm joined now by our sports
correspondent rob harris and rob what a
time this is for tennis it feels like
the end of an era serena williams
retiring and now roger federer
yeah the passing from the game the
departure of another great roger federer
announcing his retirement we can debate
who perhaps is the greatest of all time
and based on number of slams won novak
djokovic and rafa nadal have overtaken
roger federer now but
certainly by other barometers the most
weeks at number one in the world
rankings 237 weeks at number one he's
really set a mark in his graceful style
over the years and certainly his
longevity have established roger federer
as one of the greats the fact is he won
his first slam at the age of 21 2003
at wimbledon and he's gone on to win 20
slams but we've been hearing from him
today explaining just why he has decided
to
announce his retirement from next week
and this is what federer has had to say
in terms of setting out those reasons he
said
as many of you know the past three years
have presented me with challenges in the
form of injuries and surgeries i've
worked hard to return to full
competitive form but i also know my
body's capacities and limits and its
message to me lately has been clear
i am 41 years old i have played more
than 1500 matches over 24 years tennis
has treated me more generously than i
ever ever would have dreamt and now i
must recognize when it is time to end my
competitive career the laver cup next
week in london will be my final atp
event i will play more tennis in the
future of course but just not in grand
slams or on the tour now that event he
references next week it's a europe
versus the rest of the world event at
the o2 arena in london the final chance
it will seem to watch
roger federer playing a competitive
match the 41 year old swiss finally
deciding it's time to leave the court
and
the labour cup's just an indication of
perhaps some of his post-playing plans
because he actually helped to set up
that competition five years ago